[Music]
[Applause]
you are
[Music]
amazing
this life is not an easy one
[Music]
i've got this
how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
august 1st is just a few days away and
august 1st of course is
national spider-man day spider-man first
entered the marvel comic book universe
in
amazing fantasy in august of 1962. so
now on august 1st we celebrate national
spider-man day and it looks like
sony is going to be celebrating national
spider-man
week and as crazy as it is we do not yet
have a trailer for spider-man no way
home yet sony
is releasing spider-man trailers for
other
spider-man films now the trailer that i
showed at the beginning of this video is
a
spider-man fan week promo this is going
around
everywhere online right now and it is
from sony this
is an unlisted video by sony and they
might roll it out this week
and yesterday they actually did release
a trailer for
tom holland spider-man they released a
video and they titled it catch up with
homecoming and far from home
and what's hilarious is they actually
turned off the comments
for this video because they know
everybody is just going to comment
where is the no way home trailer release
the no way home trailer
and then this spider-man fan week
celebration promo was discovered and
kudos to whoever discovered
it and it shows andrew garfield
spider-man and toby maguire spider-man
as well
now it's really hard not to read into
this i mean yes it is about to be
spider-man fan week as they're calling
it but they're promo-ing the other two
spider-man
that are reported to be in the new no
way home movie
in the promo they literally show us
every single spider-man movie from
spider-man 1
to 2 to 3 to the amazing spider-man 1-2
spider-man into the spider-verse and of
course the tom holland spider-man
homecoming franchise
now again this is all before we get a
trailer
for spider-man no way home and sony is
very well aware that fans are very very
upset that's why they disabled the
comments
of their tom holland promo video where
they talk about catching up on
spider-man homecoming and far from home
but what it looks like they're really
doing here is saying
hey watch all of these spider-man movies
because
you're gonna need to know what's going
on and of course i realized that it is
spider-man weak and they're promoting
all of the spider-man films that they've
had so far but you and i know
that sony knows what they're doing we
all know toby and andrew are going to be
in no way home sony knows that people
know so does marvel
studios and they know that everyone is
waiting for the trailer right now
and the second that this becomes public
people are going to be pretty upset
that we still don't have an official
trailer for no way home
now for those of you who have been
saying that maybe it is coming on
august 1st on spider-man day national
spider-man day maybe that's when they're
going to release it
it is a possibility but i haven't heard
anything about that
daniel rpk recently stated on twitter
that he doesn't think it's coming next
week or the week after
and i talked to my trailer guy who's
been 100 accurate in telling me when
trailers are going to come out so far
and he said he hasn't heard anything so
i wouldn't expect it to be coming on
august 1st if it does that would be an
awesome surprise but i still don't think
we're getting the trailer for another
couple of weeks at least
which is crazy because at this point in
time we're only about 5 months away from
no way home releasing in theaters
and for those of you who are worried
that the release date for the film might
be pushed back
i don't think so i haven't heard
anything about it and other movies seem
to be doing just fine in theaters
plus releasing simultaneously on disney
plus or hbo max whatever it may be
so i wouldn't worry yet if we get to
around the three and a half
three month mark before the movie comes
out we still don't have a trailer that's
when we start to worry
but in the meantime it looks like sony
is just going to continue to
tease us with these other sort of
trailers that they're releasing
hinting at but not yet revealing toby
maguire and andrew garfield in
spider-man no way home
but let me know what you think about
this spider-man fan week trailer that is
currently sitting as an unlisted video
on sony's youtube channel be sure to let
me know all your thoughts in the
comments down below and let me know who
your favorite spider-man is in the
comments as well
don't forget to subscribe and click that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos don't forget
to like the video and for live updates
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you